Welcome to this lecture on database implementation.
So in the last lecture we have looked at joint implementations and different ways to implement non-ener joints.
Today we want to continue with the remaining operators.
So, and we start with sort.
Sort is an incredibly useful operator because you can implement many of the other operators using sorting.
It is not necessarily a good idea from a performance perspective because usually we will prefer hashing over sorting.
because hashing is usually faster.
But nevertheless, sorting is a super versatile scheme.
And so if you want to minimize your implementation effort,
you can just implement sorting once
and then map nearly everything else to sorting.
For example, sort merge join.
You can do aggregation using sorting.
We can duplicate elimination, many, many other things.
So sorting is a super powerful technique.
So now, how do we sort?
Actually, we talked already in the beginning
If I remember correctly, you have implemented already external sorting at the beginning as an exercise.
Therefore, I can keep this reasonably brief, but basically what we do is,
first we load as much as we can into main memory,
and then we sort in memory using some algorithm,
and then we write out a sorted run.
So we have a randomly sorted data as input,
then I make my memory here full, I sort this memory, and then I write this to disk.
So then I have a sorted run.
So we call this a run.
Then we load the next piece in memory
and write it out and so on.
And so at the end, we have many, many sorted runs.
And now once we have this,
what we can just do is you can merge them.
And so we read them sequentially,
both of these here, we start reading this,
we start reading that.
And we always look what is the smallest
and then we create from this two sorted runs,
a larger sorted run.
There's now the merge result of this.
Now, and if we are lucky, we are done with just one merge pass.
If you're unlucky, we have to do this repeatedly to handle the merge factor.
So it could be that we cannot merge an arbitrary number of runs,
but for example, only two, and then we have to do this, of course, multiple times.
Okay, so this is a very high level strategy for external sorting.
Now, how you really implement this, so there are many, many details here,
how what we can do to how we vary the implementation.
And first let's talk about the generic algorithm here.
So this is sort as producer consumer model, leaving out all the details, at least the
critical details.
So this is true basically for all implementations here.
So when we ask the sort-rater to produce data, we just ask our own input here to produce
data.
So at this point you get all the data.
Now we flush whatever we have into disk, because it could be that we still have data
and disk.
And then we merge the partitions and we have only one partition left.
And now our problem is trivial because this partition is now sorted.
So what we do is we just loop here over all tuples in my sorted partition and offer each
tuple here to my consumer.
So I just say here it is tuple, tuple, tuple.
And when we get a tuple here, this consume function, so then we check if we have still
space.
If yes, we just store it in memory.
not so my memory is full i flush my memory and afterwards i have new space i can store the data
okay so this is high level how sorting works of course the what i left out here are how do
these functions work yeah flush and merge so this is basically the critical questions so what do i
do if my memory is full what do i do after i have written out sorted runs so these are basically the
the design points I have when implementing sorting.
Okay, and now the easy solution for flushing is,
you make your memory full,
then you call quick sort.
Yeah, so at this point,
of course everything is sorted.
Now you write everything out and release memory.
Okay, good thing, easy to implement.
Also the sort algorithm is fast.
Now quick sort, if you implement this carefully,
it's a very fast algorithm.
a good choice if you implement this carefully.
Now, strictly speaking, there are better ways to do this.
Of course, depends on your definition of better, but at least if you expect that you have a
slow external memory, so if you go to disk basically, then we might favor the second
solution here.
Namely, we implement not quicksort, but heapsort with replacement selection.
Okay, now what does this mean?
This is actually a very interesting technique.
So I hope you all remember how heapsort works.
So we have here an array, this is a sorted heap.
So my smallest limit is here.
So I just create some random heap here.
Now let's say, so this here for example would be a heap.
So every element is smaller than its children, and this is true here, so this here is sorted,
it satisfies the heap condition.
Now if a new value comes, so let's say we want to insert for example, so basically what
So when the tuples come, we first fill the element to the heap until the heap is full.
Now a new tuple comes.
For example, now comes the value, let's say, 6.
So my heap is full.
I cannot put 6 in the heap.
What I do now is I write out the smallest element, the 0.
So I write 0 here to my, so then I remove the 0.
I replace it with the last element in my heap, 5.
Now I restore the heap condition.
I see this here violates the heap condition, therefore I swap the 5 here with the small
of my two children, so this here 5 and 2.
Yeah and sorry, now again restore the heap condition, this is again violated here,
so we swap these two here.
So now heap condition is restored and I have a free space.
So I can insert 6 into my heap and this in fact fits here.
Heap condition is satisfied.
So now I have successfully inserted 6.
Now I just wrote a 0 and I insert them.
So I can continue doing this until I can continue adding new elements.
So it takes the smallest element from the heap, insert a new element into the heap until
hit an element that is smaller.
For example, the next element I would remove the two,
of course, so then here again,
I would restore the heap condition.
I would swap this, for example,
with different ways to implement this,
but once I swap it with six again,
and now as the heap condition is violated,
so I repair this, I swap this here with three,
and then this six,
CSE evaluation so then I swap this again and now my heap condition is restored.
Okay now but now what happens if somebody now tries to insert a 1?
So as soon as the new value that is coming is a 1.
So this of course I can no longer add it to my heap, of course I've already written out 2.
So if I would add my 1 into my heap I would violate my sort order.
Therefore, what I do now is I say, okay, I reduce my heap by one.
So it might make a double bar.
You say, okay, my heap could just got one element smaller.
And instead I store the one into a new heap on the other end.
And so my heap, but I can continue running my current elements again, but if a new element
comes, so one I have to add to my extra heap.
But if the next element that would come would for example be a 12,
then I could take the 3 here next out.
It takes the 3, swap it here with 6,
restore the heap condition.
So first remove this, restore the heap condition,
heap condition is violated, swap 6 and 4.
6.
Now heap condition is satisfied.
So this is the heap again.
I have a free space.
So I enter this wave and then done.
Okay.
So I 12 I can do.
And so of course, as long as my elements are roughly increasing, I can easily add them
to the heap.
If I get outliers, so outliers that are smaller than the smallest value that I have added,
I add them to the end of the heap and the heap shrinks over time.
And at some point, of course, my heap is empty.
So my first heap is empty.
Everything is in the second heap.
And then at this point, I stop a run and I use a new space that I have as new heap.
Okay.
So this is called replacement selection, heap sort of this replacement selection.
And the good thing is if you do this, you produce a longer runs than if you do quicksort,
because in a quicksort you only write a run that is as large as your memory.
With replacement selection is larger than your memory, as we see in the example.
Now, how much larger, depends.
But, so, I mean, there are some cases you can see if,
one is if your input is already sorted or nearly sorted,
you write out only one run, which is super great,
because it's not that uncommon that input is sorted.
Like if a relation that is sorted by date roughly,
because people insert in the date order,
so that if you want to sort this result by date,
replacement section will create a single run.
While Quicksort would cut this into many paces.
And on average, we can see that we expect that the run length that we get is twice as
long as my memory size.
Best case, one run.
Typical case, double memory size.
And if you look in the book, The Art of Computer Programming by Knuth, he shows why we expect
double run as input.
implementation of this in detail.
Okay.
So this is great.
So replacement selection actually is better than Quicksort.
If you go to disk.
Now, the only unpleasant thing is, I mean, replacement selection is good.
If you input it has fixed lengths, because then I can easily remove and replace.
If you have variableized size input, then the replacement selection is
actually quite difficult to implement.
It can be implemented, but this is much more difficult to implement.
If you have variable six Quicksort, of course, the system has an analysis problem.
Okay.
Okay, now what about, this is a flush side,
now what about the merge side?
So usually we merge on the fly,
which means we take all my runs here.
So, and so the first run, second run, third run, and so on.
And we read all of them in parallel,
and we always output the smallest element.
Okay, only question is how do we find the smallest element?
And because in theory here,
this could be a large number,
at least a reasonably large number, so some N here.
and you all have to find the smallest element
from n things here.
The best way to implement this is,
I mean the naive way,
the really naive way, of course we don't do.
The really naive way would be to loop over all elements
and fix the smallest.
Don't do this, terrible runtime.
Okay, don't do this.
Better way, use a priority queue.
Only problem is this is especially kind of priority queue
here, namely we take the smallest element out
and then we want to replace it
So for example, if this here is the smallest one, a one, then a five, then in my priority queue,
I would have that one is the smallest for that one here, and that four is the smallest from that one.
Also, then I would want to remove one and replace it with five.
And you can do this, of course, using a regular priority queue, like a heap,
but you can do better. The most efficient way to implement this is tree of losers,
which is also explained in the book by Knuth.
or you can have some other fancy data structures
that priority queues that allows you
to do updates efficiently.
So weak heaps, for example, or some other implementation.
A regular heap is also quite okay.
You do, unfortunately,
so the naive A to implement this does twice
the number of comparisons to a tree of losers.
So tree of losers improves the number of comparisons
by factor two, but nevertheless,
it's not a super great difference.
Even a naive heap would be okay
because at least you get logarithmic cost.
And now the only question is,
what do you do with N is too large?
Because depending on your hardware,
it could be that you cannot merge
an arbitrary number of runs.
I mean, historically, when we,
I think at the beginning of this lecture,
I talked, I'm sure if I really did this,
but usually I do, perhaps I didn't use this recording.
Usually I talk about external memory sorting
with tapes, because this is where the people
who invented external memory sorting.
And of course there you can only merge,
many tape drives you have.
If you have four tape drives,
you can only merge four runs, of course.
In red, you can merge less
because you have to also write to the output.
But so you have a limited number of devices that you can read.
If you read from SSDs,
this might not be an issue for you,
then you can really merge a high number,
perhaps not an unbounded high number,
because at some point it becomes inefficient
to read from so many runs.
So if you have too many runs,
then you do a partial merge,
which means you take a number of runs
that you can merge and produce a larger run
from this and you do this until a total merge becomes feasible.
So this is how you implement external memory sorting.
Now, what other operators do we need?
One here, what we need for SQL, of course, is group by.
So let's say if somebody says,
So it says here select some X from group by Y.
And also this is supposed to be an X.
So the easiest way to implement this is you take your input, you sort it by Y, because
Because then you know that the xy pairs, xy, so x4y5, x10y5, if you sort them, of course
the aggregate is trivial.
Because I just read my input sequentially, I sum up these numbers, I sum up that numbers
and then I am done.
So when my input is sorted, problems are solved.
Trivial aggregation.
Only problem is of course I have to sort and sorting is not cheap.
Sorting is n log n, so this is not exactly cheap to do.
The alternative is to use a hash based group by.
So in that case, if you would aggregate into a big hash table, this works fine as long
as everything fits.
If my data does not fit in memory, then I have to split my hash table to disk and then
I have to merge the split partition.
join if you think about this and so this is why we built a hash table just in a hash join
as long as everything fits great if it doesn't fit i split my input into partitions organized by
hash value and then i merge within a partition so i have to read the partition again and then find
duplicates and then merge them okay so the so this is the implementation here for an in-memory group
by so we initialize a hash table in the beginning of course and then i
when i reproduce and i read my input and afterwards everything is done actually so
after my input is processed i have already the results so therefore i can to produce my output
i just scan all groups in my hash table and i output each group to my consumer okay now so the
real aggregation work is performed here and the consume function so in the consume function a new
So this example comes and I assume I group by a here.
So this is my group by attributes.
And so I check in the hash table,
if a group with, for the values a already exists,
if yes, I update the group.
So if I have a sum, I increase the sum of whatever I do.
So if I count, I increase the count.
So at this point,
you update my aggregation functions here.
Otherwise I create a new group for this, for this value.
So therefore I had the examples here,
but as I said, I think x, y was something like
five six five uh seven five uh two six eight six and something like this so i would now in this
case it's sorted of yes it's really easy no assume that this is not sorted i don't know that this is
sorted so i want to do it hash based so uh so these values now come to me so the first value comes
i check in the mesh table it's empty so i create a new group say okay for the for the value five
My aggregation is now 3.
Okay, next tapple comes,
I again check here 5,
and now I update my aggregate here from 3 to 6.
Next value comes, I update my aggregate from 6 to 13.
Then the next value comes,
oh, and I have this group I don't have already,
so I therefore create a new group with 2.
Next value comes, I update the group where my value was to 8.
And that's it.
Okay, actually quite simple to implement.
Oh, no, I said it's quite simple to implement.
What is potentially not so simple is,
whatever it means, some count is okay.
But what about min max?
Yeah, so you can also maintain min and max.
And for some attributes that here,
if these are numbers, no problem,
it just works just the same.
If these are strings, that's not so easy
because it could be that the smallest
but also the smallest, is larger than the initial value that you get.
So the first time you see this group, you see a certain string value,
but there could be other string values that are, in sort order, greater or less,
but in length are longer.
And this is of course a problem, and there are different ways to tackle this,
but the easiest way to tackle this is to reserve the maximum space,
because you know how long the values can be at most, you can derive this from the schema.
So you reserve enough space to the data can store those.
So the longest possible string,
then you can also evaluate min and max.
Or alternative would be you reallocate,
so you create a new group.
So different ways to implement this.
But let's say variable length is a bit tricky.
But without variable length everything is okay.
So this was the basic primitive.
So we have already talked to join, sort, group by.
There are some other stuff you can do in a deadweight system and one particular thing
we can do are the set operations.
So union, intersect, accept.
They, in a first glance, look a bit like a join actually.
Intersect, you want to find everything that occurs left and right.
So this is a bit like a join, same as accept looks a bit like an anti-join, but they behave
slightly different.
So therefore we look at different ways to implement this.
repetition here you hope you all know the difference between intersect and intersect all
and the same for the other ones the left side here has set semantic the right hand side here has
multi-set or back my back is a different name for what is that my t set semantic now or back
so which means that the ones with all do allow duplicates whereas the one without all remove
duplicates. Set is duplicate free, a mighty set can have duplicates.
So therefore we have some treat them somewhat differently. Okay so first we
look at union all means this is trivial, this does nothing. So union all is a
trivial set operation, the only trivial set operation actually. We just take two
relations and union them and keep them. So here we say we take two tuppled
streams, I get two tuppled streams as input, it just concatenates them. So
So everything from the left, then everything from the right, and that's it.
I might have to rename attributes depending on how it's implemented.
This does nothing.
So most likely, here is nearly no code.
Most likely this operator here does nearly nothing.
Here we just execute one operator, we execute another operator, that's it.
We might have to do some renaming, but it's trivial.
So no work is performed.
So this is really easy.
This one here is not so easy.
So we, namely, so this, now we have to remove duplicates.
So what we can, could do is we could first run a union all and then remove duplicates.
This is actually a valid way to implement this.
So this is what we see here.
We say E1, union E2 is the same as running E1, union E2 with duplicates.
So allowing duplicates is we draw by doing this bar here on top of this union operator.
So this means we do a union all, we allow duplicates.
And afterwards we group everything here by the attributes.
And this of course removes duplicates.
Here group by removes duplicates.
Therefore this is one way to implement union.
Now what we could do instead is we could directly write everything into one hash table.
Like we built a hash table and store everything from the left and everything
from the right in the hash table.
this could be a tiny bit more efficient than running a group I operator but in
reality this is nearly no difference and so this union is nearly identical to
group I just union all into group I also in fact you can implement this it's the
same now what about the others so intersect so an intersect is similar to
a semi-join so basically E1 intersect E2 is roughly the same as E1 semi-join E2.
I say roughly the same because it's only the same if E1 is duplicate free.
Now so if you have no duplicate in E1 then we can in fact evaluate and intersect with the semi-join.
What we can do is we can figure it out during the build phase.
So basically we put one of the two sites into a hash table
and by building the hash table,
we can recognize if there are duplicates
and if yes, we remove them.
And so we don't store duplicates in the hash table.
And then afterwards, my hash table is duplicate free.
And then I can run a semi-join.
And if I have already a joint partner,
I don't output the joint partner again.
So just use a marking technique that we saw before.
that you saw for semi-join so we remember if you have a joint partner if not we output this now
so this is one way to implement this or alternative if you look at how to implement
the intersect all this we see in the next slide and then we we implement it basically using like
intersect equivalent to intersect all slightly different of course but equivalent now from a
performance perspective this here is actually the more efficient one but on the other hand you have
to implement the intersect all anyway.
Therefore we can also lift into the intersect all
implementation if you want.
I have over my time implemented both strategies.
Now, so using intersect all is easier.
A separate implementation is a bit more efficient.
Okay, so how do we implement intersect all?
Yeah, so it is this intersection with Beck semantic
and this is defined over the characteristic function.
Now, what does this mean characteristic function?
this is basically the frequency function.
So the frequency function tells you
how often an element occurs in a set.
So like if you look at this multi-set here,
I draw this as a multi-set,
three, four, five, five, six, six, six, seven.
And I want to intersect this with this set here
that says one, five, five, six, six, nine.
So by the way, if you intersect these,
then we get as a result here,
what is that?
5, 5, 6, 6.
Okay.
This is the answer.
And now how can we figure this out?
And we look at the frequencies of these.
We see the value of three occurs once.
The value of four occurs once.
The value of five occurs twice.
The value of six occurs three times.
The value of seven occurs once.
The other side says the value 5 occurs 2 times,
the value 6 occurs 2 times, that's it.
And I'm sorry,
value 1 occurs once,
5 2 times,
6 2 times,
9 1s.
Okay, and we say,
if we look at these frequencies here,
we see in the intersect,
and by the way,
this is called a characteristic function
because this is a bijective mapping
between the set and these frequencies.
You can deduce one from the other.
And we can compute intersection now,
of the frequencies. So we say, we look at the value of three, minimum frequency of the both
tiles is zero, so it's not in the set. So one's the same, one minimum frequency is one, so min,
frequency. So four minimum is zero, five minimum is two, therefore we have two in the set, six
minimum is two, two in the set, seven, zero, nine, zero.
Okay.
So we look basically look at the frequencies of both sides.
We count them.
Then we take the minimum of both and then we output them.
Okay.
And how do we compute this?
If we just use a group by,
and so because counting is just what a group by operator does.
And so basically we do,
we take to these two sets, one,
We compute this, we compute R1, R2.
Here we compute a union all,
and then we do a group by,
and then of course here we have to remember
that we have come from the left.
So basically we have to compute here a value
that says F is one, F is two or something like this.
We have to figure out if you're left or right.
Then we group by A,
and here we then we say,
here we sum up the values where f is 1, we sum up the values where f is 2.
Now I have gets accounts for left and right and after at the end here I filter that,
I compute the minimum of these two and then I shouldn't use filter here, I use unnest basically.
unless the coil this here count one count two and unless this here on min c1 c2 okay
so i take the minimum of these two counts and i replicate the tuple as as often as the minimum
of these two counts and this is exactly the semantic of intersect all you know so i count
both sides and adjust expenses it's a good thing about this strategy is we have everything already
Un-gen-oil is trivial, group I with all, also un-nest, we didn't talk about un-nest, but
trust me, un-nest is a trivial operator.
We just take an integer value and then we replicate the tuple as often as the integer
value is.
So this is very easy here and therefore it's pretty simple to implement.
And so we can use the standard algorithm that we have, we can also use this in external
memory, everything is possible.
now um we can do slightly better if you are in memory because the way i have sketched it is we
would count the occurrences on the left and on the right yeah so this is on the other hand if my
memory is if my hash table is in memory and i get a trouble from the right where no value from the
left exists yeah so i can immediately throw it away so basically if i do intersect all here of
R1, R2, and I get an R2 value,
and I have no corresponding entry in memory,
I will never create a new group,
if everything has fit.
And because I know that obviously,
the count on the left must be zero,
if it is not in the memory,
therefore I can never find,
I never produce a non-zero count,
I can immediately throw the tablet away.
And so this is a small optimization
that can be done here,
if everything did fit in memory.
case we can do slightly more efficient.
And so the trick for intersect all is to go over the
frequencies to the counts of the occurrences.
Okay.
And now the last set operation that we're missing is accept.
So this is roughly like an anti-join,
the same argument as with intersect intersect
with the same join, except it's an anti-join.
And so we want to output everything from
E1 that does not exist in E2.
Again, only if it's duplicate free,
with a non-inner joint implementation,
we can handle this using a flag.
And so we can have a flag,
did I have a joint partner?
Yes or no, I never output it.
Oh no, in this case it's safe anyway.
Oh no, no, it's not safe.
And it's not super safe.
Of course, yeah, it's a,
now I must build a hash table over E1 to do this.
And so then if I do this,
then I can figure out if I have duplicates.
Or alternatively we use this,
you know what's coming.
for x accept all and accept all basically works like like intersect all
only in x in intersect all we did minimum in exact all we do minus now so
this is exact all again defined over the characteristic function occurred
accounts occurrences left and right just just identical to intersect all the
only difference is in this line here yeah namely in this line we say in the
In the exact case we take the minimum frequency, in the except case we subtract the occurrences
from the left, we say occurrences from the left minus occurrences from the right.
That is if we reduce frequency, so if a value occurs three times on the left and two times
on the right, then the output of course is 1, 3, because 1 did survive, so these cross
each other out, the 1, 3 survived.
Of course, if the right hand side occurs more frequencies, more values on the left, then the output is zero.
Therefore, the ABC is the maximum here of zero and subtraction.
Okay, but basically if you know how to do intersect all G, you also know how to do except all.
Basically the same, only the computation is slightly different.
And also here this same argument holds as in the intersect case.
In the in-memory case, if we don't find a group in memory, we can immediately stop.
We don't have to create a group.
And so we don't have to count if we are sure that my count will be zero in the end anyway.
And so we can do this small optimization.
So this was the end of my operator.
So now we have seen all operators that we need for SQL.
No, first let me check if this is true.
Did forget any?
No, I think this is in fact, at least for basic SQL, this is enough for window function.
but for basic SQL, this is enough.
You can express everything that we have in SQL using these operators.
Okay.
What we did not talk about yet is this section here, code generation.
Now we have mentioned repeatedly that when we want to evaluate
operators and expressions, we have to do something.
So we have to produce something into executable form.
And today I want to look a bit at how we can really do this.
Okay.
So basically for performance reasons,
we will have to compile my,
at least my operator subscripts,
potentially even some part of the operators themselves
into some kind of executable form.
Now, what is executable form?
Now we have freedom here.
So we could use bytecode.
I've sketched you an implementation using bytecode,
or we could generate machine code.
So real executable code.
and of course from a performance perspective machine code is best so you want to produce
machine code this is the most efficient it's also the most difficult but i think at this point you
i hope already did an exercise where you did this yourself i think you will you did already an
exercise where you generated machine code and um generating machine code is really fun so it's not
that not as daunting as you might think and performance of course is great very fast.
Now historically generating machine code was a bit of fraud upon because you have
of course you have portability issues like you can generate machine code for one machine
but then a new processor comes up and they know what you do then yeah.
And fortunately in the past people were hesitant to do this. So the very very first
a relational database system, system R, started by generating machine code, but then they wanted
to port the system to a new machine, then said, oh, should I reimplement all my machine
code generation?
They said no, they switched instead to an interpretation framework.
And so they went away.
Nowadays you no longer have to do this because what you can do is you can just use existing
code generation frameworks for you.
So you don't have to implement it yourself.
So some well known toolkits here are for example LLVM and this I will probably recommend for you.
So this is very matured, easy to use and works just fine.
So LLVM is a very good choice.
There is not the only one, there are other toolkits you can use, LitJit, GNU, Lightning
or another one that we have used also is this one here, SMJIT.
So there are different frameworks you can use to generate machine code for you.
but definitely you really want to use a framework.
You probably don't want to generate machine code yourself.
It's too difficult and also not worth the effort.
Other people have done this already.
Why should you implement it yourself?
And if you use such a toolkit,
then generating machine code is not that difficult.
It's actually quite easy.
Many of these even offer you some optimization,
so they can even improve the code that you generate
to make it faster to execute.
In particular, LVM supports this.
Okay, and we will talk a bit about how to do this.
So now LAVM, so name LAVM by the way
is low level virtual machine.
So it means it abstracts away a computer,
but it's a pretty low level abstraction.
So this looks, if you ever saw assembler code
for a real assembler code, I mean,
the language of LAVM looks a bit like assembler code.
So they have very low level primitives,
but it's not real assembler.
if you wish a high level assembler that extracts away from you some of the problems.
So now what is our characteristic properties here? First we pretend as if you would have
an unbounded number of registers. In the real machines is not true of course. So a real processor
has, depending on which processor you use, but if you use a 64-bit Intel for example,
you have 16 general purpose registers that you can use.
If you use the 32-bit until you have only six,
but you shouldn't do this.
Now six is really too little.
And 64-bit mode, we have 16,
which is at least some reasonable number.
Other processes have even more.
Now, but nevertheless,
you will have a significant number of registers.
At some point you will run out of registers
and you will have to store your values on the stack instead,
because you cannot keep them on registers.
But LVM hides this problem for you.
So in LVM, you can just pretend
many as you need and this is how the code looks like here this is a definition of a small lvm
fragment and this defines a factorial function so we compute factorial here so we define the
function factorial we get an argument x so therefore what you do here first if we say okay
let's compare x with one we check if x is larger than one if this is the result of this comparison
is taught in this register's unnamed register just gets the value one so unnamed register one
as you need so this is a comparison if this is true so this is a boolean flag here if this is
true we jump to a one otherwise we'll jump to a two so you see already the second characteristic
here unbounded number of registers and strongly typed so each register has a type here namely
and this year register one is a boolean register x is an 32-bit integer and so we have a type
attached to the register so if the weight is larger than one then we jump to label one this is here
What we do then is we subtract one from x
and we call factorial of,
so we subtract x one from x.
This gives us a new value register two.
And then we call factorial recursive passing
this new value two here.
And then we take the result,
this is stored here,
multiplies with x and that's it.
And otherwise we directly jump here.
So now here something funny happens.
This is a phi node.
Now what is a phi node?
Or actually, why do we need phi node?
There's a second, a third property that is probably unusual the first time you see this,
namely, it uses single static assignment, which means you can, once you have assigned
a value to register, you can never change it.
And so here we have assigned a value to register one and register one now has this value and
this can never be changed.
And single static assignment is great for, if you want to analyze data flow, because
we know that values never change. So data flow analysis is much easier if we have single static
assignment. The only problem is now what do you do with loops, for example. So if you would do a
for loop here, we say for x in one to 10. So how do you implement this? If I cannot update x,
so I can assign one to x, but I cannot update x. So how do we translate this?
yeah so and um this is done using phi nodes so phi nodes are ways to to create new values
depending on where you come from so basically we want to translate this we have we do this using
three bodies here we say before the loop before then we have the loop body
and then we have after the loop okay so and before the loop we do nothing basically we just say
uh branch to body
put quality okay now within the within the loop we have this variable x we say this variable x
Now what is x?
We say x is finite
and we say we take the value one
if we come from before.
Yeah.
And we take the value we don't know yet.
We will see what value we take otherwise.
Okay, so this is my x value.
So then by, and I can do something with my x.
So now the next value of course is,
next is x plus one.
And then I check, I need more space unfortunately.
Next is as n is x plus one, then continue is,
is n is less than 10, less than equal to 10.
Okay, and then we say conditional branch,
when condition C is true, then we go to loop,
else we go to after.
Okay, and then here is after.
Then of course here something continues.
And now you see what we put here in the fine node, namely, the first time we run into the
loop we take the value one, of course we start with one.
And the second iteration, so when we come from our own loop here, then we take the value
n.
And then when we come from loop, take n, the first time you take one, when you come from
from yourself, you take N.
So this is what the final does.
And this allows you to express this without updating.
Notice this value X here is never updated.
And if we assign X once, that's it.
And so this is the first time you see this,
this takes some time to get used to,
but this has many good properties.
So single-septic assignment is very good.
And so you want to use this
because you can generate much better code for this,
much easier we can generate code for this.
Okay.
we also need to find out, namely when we,
to distinguish between control flow.
So when we took the branch, we did recursive call,
then we computed the value, this one here.
If we did not take the branch,
then we want to output the value one.
And this is what we see here.
We say the value five is computed as,
if we took the branch, then we take the value four.
If we did not take the branch, then we take the value one.
Okay.
And then, then we output the result of five.
So this computes a factorial function.
And you probably have already played with this
in the exercises.
So, and we can take this here
and can take a second to flash the framework
and we can produce code reasonably easy.
Yeah, so as long as we only compute scalar expressions
like plus minus comparison or so on,
we can directly translate this to LVM.
It's very easy because maps more or less to one of these maps to a few LVM instructions.
That's easy.
So if you just load this scalar value into LVM registers, you might need more registers
for null indicators.
So if you have to handle NILs and we need something, but yeah, so here's basic primitives.
We just directly map to LVM instructions.
It's very easy.
Now, some operations of course are complicated like predicate.
is this is a bit like a simplified regular expression.
This is complicated.
For this, it doesn't make sense to generate code.
Now this is a lot of code
and the code is always the same.
It doesn't depend on the query.
Therefore we just implement this once,
regular in C++ and then we call this from LVM
because our generated code can call existing code just fine.
And so we can mix existing code and generated code.
Therefore this one is something that is clearly called
while other stuff is generated.
try to generate code that minimizes branching
and minimizes the number of function codes.
As you don't want to call it unnecessary functions.
On the other hand,
there's also we don't want to generate a needless code.
Therefore there's a certain trade-off here
between compile time and execution time.
But nevertheless, expressions are easy.
The real challenge here is how,
what do we do with the sets?
yeah and so if you want to want to translate set operations so like join and group by and so on
then we have to do something different because lvm of course only handles individual values it's
knows nothing about relational algebra so um so for this we need some some different mechanism
Okay, and how do we do that?
So of course, what we have looked already at different ways to implement to evaluate
operators and we have seen the iterator model which is very widely used.
But in reality, the iterator model does not really mimic like CPUs work.
I mean, the iterator model is in a way natural, if you have implemented your, if you have
it directly follows the relation algebra.
So therefore people have used this.
But if you think about what was the kind of computations
that we perform, yeah,
then the iterator model does not really match
what we would like to do.
Because what we want is we would want to have locality.
Like we want to touch data as rarely as possible.
Yeah, and we want to do as much as we can
on a single piece of data before we look at the next,
and there's the next one.
So locality is important for performance.
And this observation here brings us to the idea
data-centric query execution that's written here.
So basically the first rule here, as we say, we should read and write data as
rarely as possible because reading and writing is expensive.
I mean not super expensive it's in memory, but it is expensive.
Your memory is relatively slow compared to your CPU.
And so the corresponding property is we will want to keep data in CPU
registers as much as we can.
because CPU registers are much faster than memory.
And furthermore, what we see is the code
should center around the data,
not the data move according to the code,
because this is what happens in the iterator model.
In the iterator model,
the code corresponds to the logical operators
and we pass data between operators.
Like we make copies or we store it somewhere.
But we pass data between code fragments,
but this is not what we should do.
We should instead organize the code in a way
that data is touched as rarely as possible.
And the good thing is if you do this,
you increase locality,
like you touch the same part of the data repeatedly
and you reduce branching,
which is also good for performance.
Okay, so these are the high level ideas of the approach.
Now I want to show you an example how to do this.
So here we see data-centric execution
on a picture here with visible pipeline boundaries.
So we see what we compute here.
We take three relations, one, two, three.
We filter R1, we filter R2,
we group by the filter R2,
and then we take R3,
and then we join everything here together.
And if you think about what's happening here,
if you think about the pipelining,
you see the first dotted boundary here.
This is my first pipeline.
I'm drawn, oh, sorry.
I messed it up now.
So I draw a boundary about this.
This is my first pipeline.
So what we do here is we read everything from R1,
we filter and then we write everything into a hash table.
So this is one part.
So if we want to execute this all together
because we touch the data from R1,
then we write it back.
We want to execute this in one piece.
And the same here with R2,
we read everything from R2,
we filter, put it in a hash table,
we read the hash table,
put it into another hash table
here we read r3 and probe to hash tables and we want to execute. So this is how the data flows.
We want that my code follows the data flow basically. And therefore what we want to do
now is instead of iterating over the data in the iterator model, we want to use a push model
and we push the data through the pipeline and we see how this works.
So the corresponding code that we want to get for this is this one here. And you see that next
to the code we have this brackets here and each bracket corresponds to one pipeline.
So this here is the first pipeline, namely that one here, the first pipeline. We say,
we loop over all tuples in R1, we check the condition and at the end we store them in the
hash table. So this is one piece of code and we want to execute it like this. So this here corresponds
to the push model. We push it up and we generate code for exactly this sequence here. Okay, then
Then the next pipeline here, the second pipeline here, second, third and fourth.
Second pipeline, we loop over everything in R2, we filter and put it in a hash table,
three we read the hash table, build a new hash table and four, loop R3, probe the first
hash table, probe the second hash table and then output the result.
So this is the kind of code that we want to get and this is also the kind of most of compact
code that you can imagine.
Compare this to what would happen in the iterator model.
The iterator model model would jump all over the code,
all the place.
Here we have small tight loops that read data,
do something, write data.
This is always a primitive.
And we touch data as rarely as possible.
So therefore the strategy here,
we are producing operator loops
over all materializing tuples.
So the current tuple is loaded into CPU registers.
All pipelining and system operators are applied.
and then the tuples materialize into the next pipeline breaker.
And our goal here is we want to maximize code and data locality.
And we have a tight loop that performs the number of operations and that does everything
that we can. So we minimize memory access. So the downside, well, it's not really a downside,
but of course what happens here is that the operator boundaries are blurred.
So we no longer see the operators as clearly as before. Why? So if you think about this,
this part for example belongs to this join here and this part also belongs to this join yeah so
this this all this the one operator here is ripped apart into pieces there's a be um so we no longer
have a clearly visibility in the code what what belongs to what operator so this is distributed
all over the place but on the other hand this is a good thing i mean first time you see this
to the iterator model, but performance wise, this is a good thing.
And because we, we perform the work when it's appropriate, yeah.
And we don't want to jump, don't want to pass data around just to keep my code
nicely following the operator model.
Okay.
So therefore this is actually a good property here.
Yeah.
So the code centers around the data and not on the operators.
Okay.
This is what we get now.
Now, so this chapter here is called code generation.
So how do we generate the code?
So we now have to write code basically
that generates this code for us.
And we do this by using a produce-consume interface
that we already talked about
in the event we talked about the different models.
Now, the big difference here is that
the produce-consume function do not really exist.
So this is a concept basically.
So, I mean, when we talked about the push model,
I pretended like the operator would really have a produce
and consume function and I showed you how to implement this.
But in reality, this function doesn't exist.
Instead, what we do is we generate a generator code
that has a produce logic.
So that generates a code that produces tuples.
And we have a consume logic that generates codes
that accepts incoming tuples.
If it is in the generative code,
you no longer see the produce, consume.
If you think about this example here,
this is a push model,
but you don't see a single call to produce and consume.
It's simply invisible.
There's no, conceptually there is produce, consume here,
but in the code, it's no longer visible.
Okay, so therefore, how can we produce this code?
So, and this is now here,
So this is a real C++ sketch here, how to do this.
Basically when we have a hash join
and we ask the hash join, please produce code.
What we do is we ask my left part here, produce code.
And this will now generate code that produces code.
And also here we call this drive plan function
and produce the code.
And then we ask my right side lies,
the producer code and then we can call this okay then we generate calls we
put we perform a call so this is a call to a hash join here from from c++ okay
and there's this and in the consume function here so this is a consume that
we get and the consume checks okay do I get a table from the left or from the
right if it's from the table from the left what we will do here is we collect
by values note that this all happens here at compile time not at execution time and so therefore we just remember okay
What are the columns that I will that I will need so I collect here in a vector
So corners but only as IDs basically I couldn't collect IDs of all columns that I will need I store them here and then I will
Use a helper function helper function that computes the size of the tuple
I use a function that computes the hash value of the tuple and this helper function now they generate real code, okay?
and then we call a function that says okay please store this tuple here and the left in a hash table
and this is this is a size and this is my hash value and as a result you will get a pointer to
where your tuple should be now so this here is now a pointer where your tuple should be then you
generate new code that really materializes the tuple into the hash table okay so this is how you
generate this and in the end you end up really with producing code that looks less like this
is a protocol of course but you generate exactly this code here where we said this materialized t
in hash table this is just the example that we have seen okay and uh so the same for the right
side of course when you get tupper from the right side comes we now this year is made for uh for an
external memory has joined.
So therefore we also materialize the right-hand tuple.
And here you see already we say we spool to disk if needed.
So we start tuple to disk and then we write it.
If you would do an in-memory case, then we would not materialize the right-hand
side, but we would just do probe and then perform the lookup.
Okay.
And so then the,
when we, when we, this is a joint function basically.
I get a tuple from my left tuple, pointed to my left tuple, pointed to the right tuple.
I load by both values in the registers.
Yeah, so this is here we call helper function says dematerializer, which says load my left tuple.
And so what I need for my left tuple in register, load my right tuple.
Then here I say I call helper that says, okay, test the joint condition.
So I compared my left values with my right values.
If the predicate is false, please jump here.
So this is a basic block, so a label,
labeling you generate code where you jump to
of the conditions false.
Now, then you might have some residual predicates
or the residual predicates are predicates
that are not equal conditions.
Like you could say, I want that A like B or something.
You cannot evaluate this with a hash join.
Therefore we check them afterwards.
This is what we do in this loop.
The loop of all residual conditions,
we derive the values.
This is a Boolean value now.
Then here we check if the condition is true.
and so this is an if, but note that this here is not a regular if, but this is a code gen if.
And so we now generate code for an if.
Yes, if you check if the condition is true and if it's false, then we jump to this label here,
jump to false.
Otherwise we did find a match.
So if I look at my parent operator and call consume and then do something.
But know that this consume here that we call is called at compile time, not execution time.
generates code there to do something with the tupler.
Okay.
So this is how we can generate code.
Now let me briefly check my time.
Yeah, I realized, unfortunately,
you might have noticed this,
that we are coming uncomfortably close
to the end of the semester,
not to say this is the last lecture, unfortunately.
And my timing was not ideal.
So I mean, I will not squeeze everything in here,
wanted to do a code generation because I think this is one of the more interesting and useful
parts of a lecture and I also want to cover parallel execution I will probably not be able
to cover the rest of the lecture but this is okay but at least the most important parts I still
wanted to do therefore we will use the remaining time to look at parallel execution this is a
particular interesting thing because I mean, yeah, but there might be multiple reasons why you want to
use a parallelism. One reason of course is you might just have multiple users that are parallel,
yet run queries at the same time. Of course you want to run them in parallel, but this is trivial.
This is very easy. Now this is a not an interesting case of expert execution.
They're also relatively uninteresting, more interesting somewhat, but a bit less interesting is,
No, no, perhaps I shouldn't, I shouldn't order them like this.
So this is a boring case, first one.
Multiple users is easy.
Just run query, run another query in different threads.
It's easy.
The more challenging one is this one here.
On a modern CPU, you will have more than one core.
I mean, probably even your laptop has at least two or four cores.
And if you look at desktop machines,
the desktop machine I am currently using have 16 cores.
And you can also for affordable price get 32 cores nowadays.
latest AMD they even sell you desktop machines with 64 cores at a somewhat reasonable price and
these these start to get expensive but they're not so insanely expensive so for companies that
is perfectly affordable for a private customer probably not but for company can afford this you
so we can expect that as that a machine nowadays at least probably 16 cores up to 64 or if you have
multi-socket machines even more.
Yeah, you can build a machine for a reasonable price
that has 128 cores or so, or even more.
So you have a high number of cores.
And if you have that many cores,
of course it doesn't make sense to run single-threaded.
Because if you have 64 cores and run single-threaded,
I'm wasting 63 of my 64 cores, this is of course bad.
And therefore on modern machines,
basically parallelism is a must.
Another reason why you want to use parallelism is,
like SSDs that only give you best performance if you query them for multiple threads and
parallel.
Single threads you cannot get maximum bandwidth.
So this also forces you into parallelism but on the other hand this is a, yeah I think
the most interesting case is the second one.
We just have an inside high number of cores and we want to utilize them.
Okay, and if you look at parallelism there are different ways to parallelize interqueryl
parallelism and intraqueryl parallelism.
So interquery parallelism just means we run multiple queries simultaneously.
And so for this, we map each query to a thread and then of course we need concordial control.
But otherwise, parallelism, this kind of parallelism is for free, but that is very easy.
We just want to write one query, that is easy.
So this is not the interesting case.
The interesting case is that one here, intraquery parallelism.
And also within are two different forms, vertical and horizontal.
horizontal is in a way the uninteresting case again like there are some parts like we have
they have such such a query here you can quickly realize that these two subtrees here t1 and t2
are independent of each other they're logically independent therefore what we could do is we take
one thread that executes t1 we run one thread that executes t2 and once both are done they also
to do the group by, the subtree and the group by.
And after both threads are done, we join the result.
Okay.
Again, it's a pretty simple form of parallelism,
but also not a very useful form
because it's not that common that you have this structure.
And because we need a query basically
where we can really cut my query into pieces
and each piece is stored, materialized to disk
and on this materialism operator.
and then we can parallelize this,
but how often this is occur.
Yeah, and also you have to realize,
means there are some expensive theories
that are trivial, like this one.
We scan R and then group I.
Yeah, clearly there's only one operator,
two operators if we include this select,
but there are very little number of operators,
but this here could be huge.
Yeah, it could be that this here
is a few gigabytes of data, terabytes of data.
So then of course we must run this in parallel,
even though it's a very low number of operators.
And this is what we talked about in the last part here,
vertical parallelism.
This means we parallelize the operators themselves.
And this is the most interesting case
and also the most powerful
because if you can parallelize each individual operator,
then of course we can also parallelize the whole query.
And so this is the most powerful way to achieve this.
And now, of course, one question is how do we do this?
And when people first talked about parallelization,
they invented the mechanism
that is called exchange operators.
So basically the idea was,
we hide the fact that we run it parallel
from the operators, operators don't know this.
Instead, we encapsulate the parallelism
in explicit exchange steps
data between threads.
Okay. And so this is an example.
So this is the left side here.
You see a single thread execution.
We just take R, we filter R, then we group by.
Okay. If you want to do this in parallel,
what we could do is we cut R into pieces.
We don't say how, but for example,
this is simply the first thread, the second thread
is also just by row count or something.
And we just, so this is my big R.
we just cut R into three pieces.
R1, R2, R3.
I'm sorry, R2, R1, R2, R3.
We just cut R3, R into pieces.
Then I'd run the same operator as before.
So I filter and I do group by,
and these operators know nothing about parallelism.
So they run it parallel, but they don't know this.
Then I do an exchange, exchange 3, 1,
which means I take three inputs that come in parallel
and I output one output, so one sequential output.
to one and then I do another group by now first why do I need this clearly
because the same group can occur multiple times like the first party I
can have the group seven and then a certain value let's assume I do some
let's say I do some so then the first party I seen the value 10 for the group
seven the second part has seen the value 20 and the third part has seen the value
13.
Okay.
And the final answer of course is I must output 743.
And this is what this construct does.
We do pair thread group by, then we exchange result and then we group by again to get the
final result.
And of course we hope, we expect that these groups group by here will make the result
much smaller because this has already removed all duplicates therefore we hope that this work here
is not that much and therefore we can the final group by is not so expensive compared to the
original input so this is a hope here that we have so this is a parallelism this exchange
also historically was it was also invented for a distributed setting because you can just do the
same if you are distributed this is actually strength of the exchange multiple threads
multiple machines makes no difference.
We can handle all of them the same.
On the other hand, it's not a super powerful scheme.
So if you, I mean, there are commercial database systems
that still use this.
So ever we should know how it works and what it does.
But on today's machines,
I believe it's a scheme is largely obsolete.
And we will see in a moment what kind of problems we have.
But first let's talk about exchange,
how we can model this.
So we have, there's a basic exchange here.
we take an input and produce m outputs and there are some special variants here of this like we
can exchange union or we can we can split when we have multiple output streams we can split them
by a hash value so that we know that a certain value must be in a certain partition or we can
do a range split so we split by by data range or we can do a broadcast split which says the full
input is sent to all consumers so depending on the query that you have all of these constructs
can make sense you know so you can can express uh things using all these operators here
and um so you see here some examples how we can how we can uh process like so my original input was
i take my um so this is the thing that's right i take my r filter and group by so these things
And here is I cut my work, I group by each individual part of R and then I exchange and
then do finally group by.
I mean this here has problems with scheme if the same value occurs in all groups because
then it doesn't work that great.
So if you have everything occurs everywhere, then the final group by can be nearly as expensive
as the single traded execution.
and so if we are unlucky and so if you want to avoid this you can instead use this scheme here
so the second scheme says okay i take my input filter makes sense because everybody can filter
and then i do an exchange hash i don't group by but i do an exchange hash three three which means
i take three input streams i put two three output streams but i guarantee you that um a certain
value will only occur on one stream so for example the original i said everybody here can output the
group seven if you are unlucky if you do an x has split then i know that the seven will occur only
one of the three for example this one of course already i don't know because it depends on the
hash value but only one of them will get many threes yes three three three three everybody else
will not get threes therefore we can do a group by in this particular stream then output one seven
a further group by.
So no subsequent group by is needed.
We just do an XA in 3.1,
which means we convert the three input streams
and the one output streams, that's it.
Okay.
And so this way we avoided the duplication.
On the other hand, if you would know that this,
the partition here,
so that we would aggregate everything
into a very small group here,
and the output would be very small,
this here would be more efficient.
if there are very, very few groups after the group I.
This here is better if there are many groups
after this initial group I.
So this depends.
Or there's also something we can do,
we can combine both techniques.
So we do a local pre-aggregation.
So this is the last alternative here.
We do a local pre-aggregation,
which already removes the duplicates.
Then we do an exchange by value.
So then we now find now that this here,
we will example only get the sevens
and at most we get three sevens,
because this is three's mainboard.
And then we do another group Y and then we are done.
Okay.
So this is how we, different ways,
how we can express parallelism is exchanged.
And we can do the same with joints.
So like if we have a single threaded joint,
we can make this multi-threaded.
For example, here saying, I take my R1,
I do a hash split.
So I distribute this over three threads.
the data roughly, the same with the other side,
we distributed over three threads by hash value,
and then each thread performs a regular join.
And we know because we did the partition by hash value,
that my join partner must be come to me.
And so I know that if we get join partners,
I will not need the data from anybody else.
So therefore we can combine the final result
with the 3.1 exchange to produce a final result.
Okay.
Okay, now the good thing about exchange is
it's pretty flexible and we can run a distributed edge
and the operators don't have to know anything
about parallelism because the join,
it's a group I had no idea
that they were running multi-threaded.
So for them just looks like single-threaded.
So this is a strength where some people know it likes this,
but if you ask me today, this scheme is obsolete.
So main problem here is that the degree of parallelism
baked into the plan.
If you think about this, this plan says, okay,
I run on three threads and you run on three threads.
Now you cannot take four, you cannot take two,
at least not easily.
Four you cannot do it or two you could do
by doing multiple drops on the same threads.
But so with my parallelism is baked into the plan.
And this is highly unattractive.
Yeah, because I mean, if you have 64 cores,
my kind of, of course I can scare you 64 cores,
a query runs, a new query comes up.
I cannot take away threads easily.
So changing workload is a problem.
Second problem is, if you think about this,
here we said, let's look at this plan.
Could be that this filter condition
is nearly always false, roughly false,
roughly false for these,
which means R1 and R2 have nearly no work.
And this here is nearly always true,
whereas R3 does also work.
This leads to a high imbalance,
which means a one and a two will finish quickly
and then do nothing.
And then afterwards you run single-threaded.
All your remaining work is done
in this poor thread with the responsible for R3.
This is also bad.
So baking into the,
starting partitioning into the plan
has a lot of disadvantages.
Yeah, and also the exchange itself is pretty expensive.
Like this hash exchange,
This is expensive.
You make copies of your data all the time.
So this, if you ask me, you shouldn't do Exchange.
I mean, I teach it to you because some systems use this,
but if you ask me, Exchange is an obsolete setting.
So what we want instead is,
we want that the database system itself
understands parallelism.
Yeah. So that each operator is aware
that it's running multi-threaded
and that multiple threads can access the same data.
life more difficult.
Like now we must make sure that my data structures
are properly synchronized.
For example, if I have a hash table,
I have to somehow synchronize it
so that multiple threads can access them safely.
Yes, this is a challenge, but on the plus side,
we can now write algorithms
that really are designed for parallelism
and that can run the different relational operators
efficiently in a parallel fashion.
And one particular nice way to do this
also driven parallelism.
Now, what does this mean?
So basically we have a tension here
between flexibility and performance.
This in a way mimics,
but when we talked about blockwise processing,
it's not really because we implemented it
in a push fashion, but nevertheless,
the same observation between the iterator model
and the blockwise processing.
Iterator model is super expensive
because we do this for each individual tuple.
Blockwise is more, is cheaper
we do this and we can pass larger,
we do less calls.
For each call we process large amount of data.
Same here, we schedule work to threads
and scheduling single templates is too expensive.
But what we can do is we can,
we look into my input,
if you break my into constant size work units called morsel.
Now we call this morsel
because we aim to make this thing small.
Now, not super small,
but this should be not that large
If we mean in worst case, I could take my input
and just cut it into a chunk.
As like if I have four threads,
I just cut my input into four pieces.
This is what we don't want to do
because then we are no longer flexible.
And because this is static partitioning
just like in the exchange model.
What we want to do instead is to say, okay,
each thread processes, for example, 10,000 tuples
or a hundred thousand tuples.
And after the next, after we do,
we process 10,000 tuples, we look what happens next.
Okay, so we for each
Part here we run them. So this happens here what we see here
The first thread says okay. I take the three tuples of course already we do more but before this picture we do three
I do the first result tuples and the next thread says okay
I take the next three tuples and then they are executed in parallel
So the first thread here says okay, let's probe the table and then probe the next table
And then I write my result and I write this result into a thread local data
Because when I said about synchronization,
what I meant of course,
is that we don't want to synchronize
because synchronization between threads is expensive.
So therefore the model that we use is
we can read multiple times
because having 10 threads reads the same data
is not a problem.
But when we write,
we always write to private memory.
So that nobody else is looking at
because then we don't need synchronization.
And so therefore the first thread probes
and writes reside to local memory.
Therefore this is the color here.
So we have a second thread here, we pick data,
we probe another probe,
and then we write the results to my private memory.
And the dispatcher here says,
which thread should take which module.
Like we can have some degrees of freedom here.
First approximation, we do this round robin.
So we just take whatever's next.
This is the easiest way.
If you have a machine with NUMA,
so where some memory is more expensive to access in others,
you want to prefer reading from your local NUMA region,
prefer reading data that is sitting next to your CPU.
Therefore the dispatcher might do something smarter
than just giving you the next module.
But nevertheless, conceptually,
we just take a piece of data, then run,
and then we write.
Okay?
So the, it's, now, why do we do this
instead of static partitioning?
Because we observed that the runtime of Mercury
is dominated by the slowest threat.
Also we always wait for whoever's slowest.
In advance, we cannot know who is slowest
because it could depend on the query predicate.
Some predicate might be true for some part of the data
but in force for somebody else,
we cannot know this statically.
So this here, we see here,
for example, non-uniform distribution.
So some data might be more relevant than others.
And therefore the trick here is
we simply don't partition the data at the beginning,
but we use dynamic work stealing.
So each thread here takes, so we have a synchronized queue for small jobs.
So we say this is the jobs that I want to execute and then each thread grabs work from
the queue and if somebody is slower than somebody else doesn't matter because then the other
drops, the other threads will simply take morsels away from him.
So we say in this picture here, we say, first we say thread one, thread two, thread one,
thread two.
rate one gets slow because yeah you know it's simply predicates are more true or so then simply
could be that we take more to t2 t2 t2 t2 and then again t1 and so on yeah so we simply whoever
is finished with this model takes the next piece of work and this makes sure that the runtime of
all threads is roughly the same and because we meet each of them produces a small part of the
and therefore my total execution time
will be roughly the same for odd threads.
And this is of course ideal,
because then we don't have the straggler
for that word we're making.
Okay, and if you think about
the application interface was this,
at least a high level application interface.
If you are familiar with Intel thread building blocks,
DBB, they have a parallel four.
So which says basically we run this
and please dispatch this dynamically over threads
with work stealing.
It just uses such just a primitive as we talked about here.
Okay. And so now how do we build an in-memory hash join?
So in the build phase, each thread scans part of the input
using morsels, so taking the next end tuppets
and then processing them and materialize them.
And of course this materialization here happens
in thread local storage.
So in storage, nobody else can see.
Therefore we can just write them
without any synchronization.
After this, we have collected all tuples
in a piece of memory.
Now, the good thing is we know how many tuples we have
because we have already seen all tuples across all threads.
Of course, a single thread has not seen all tuples,
but the sum of all tuples is all threads.
So at this, after step one, one,
we know how large a hash table should be.
So now we create a hash table of appropriate size
so that everything can fit into it.
And the great advantage of doing this this way
is that we don't have to dynamically size a hash table.
Because trust me, a dynamically sized hash table
that is thread safe is a nightmare.
Either it's super slow,
or it's super complicated to implement.
And also this is terribly difficult.
Simple, therefore the answer is simply don't do this.
Collect the tuppet thread local,
and you would have to do this anyway,
because if you think about a chaining hash table,
we have a dictionary and we have a lot of buckets here.
And what we do in step one, one is we create all the buckets.
We just don't create the dictionary in the beginning, but all the buckets we can already create
And then in step 1-3 we scan over my input again
So over the buckets that have materialized and I just add these pointers here to the hash table
And this can be done in parallel because we can use if you want to enter a
Bucket here into my hash table. I look at the current entry
I put the current entry as my next entry in the next one and then I do an atomic compare exchange
please replace the pointer here to point it to myself
and do this in an atomic fashion and if the pointer has changed in the meantime so somebody
else has already put himself into this bucket then yeah i will just update my next pointer again and
try again that's why i can do this without i don't need a mutex or something so i can do this with
just using atomic operations i can add myself to this table head table i can do this in parallel
so this is here all this is parallel this is parallel this here single threaded but this is
phase, we just create the hash table.
Everything else is parallel.
And then a probe phase, this is fully parallel again.
And also we can, because in the probe phase,
we don't write to the hash table, we just read.
So when a tupper comes, we check if they're a joint partner
and therefore we don't need,
we don't have to do anything.
We can just pull, all threads can pull parallel
probe the hash table.
You have to be slightly careful here.
If you need markers, like if you think about
then we have to use atomic operations again to mark,
okay, this is marked, but nevertheless,
we can still do this in parallel.
We can do everything in parallel and then run this
and then execute this across all threads.
Okay, and this point, I think I will have to stop.
I already rushed a bit, unfortunately,
in talking about parallelism.
In the slides, we have something about main memory databases,
We will not do this because we are just, we didn't finish.
And this might have is,
let's not overdo this.
So I will, I will stop here.
I will stop before the part memory databases.
If you're interested, we will put the slides online,
of course, but you don't have to.
I mean, for a few of your future self for life,
it might be useful for you to take a look at this,
at the slides, but we will not ask this in the exam.
So you don't have to worry about that.
I, therefore I stop here.
I hope you have enjoyed as a lecture a bit.
And also I hope that you have enjoyed
the practical exercises because most things
that we do have higher practical relevance,
very useful not only for databases,
but also for other kinds of data processing tasks.
And therefore I strongly encourage you to do the exercises.
And also, of course, we will ask you similar stuff
in the final exercise.
So yeah, graded exercise that we will do.
Okay, I will stop here and thank you.